bringing new life to scrap electrical
goods Dame Scylla is repairing the motor
of an air conditioning unit he can
barely read or write but in his job he's
an expert three years ago he did an
apprenticeship here in T's and sees his
future in Senegal in Europe I wouldn't
have the papers you need to work in the
best case I'd be a street vendor I'd
never be able to work as a mechanic
there or open a workshop but here maybe
I could these three trainers at the
German funded charity as well helped
Dame sila to get to where he is today
they also put him in contact with his
current boss I didn't know him at all
but they recommended him and said he was
well trained and would do a good job
this is where Dame Scylla learned the
basics of electro-mechanics now he's
back to learn some new skills this is a
very respectable job before my
apprenticeship I worked in my cousin's
shop but my father always told me that I
should do something sensible that's why
I'm back here to learn how to wind coils
for electric motors the training center
has been here for 18 years since then
around 500 young men have come here to
learn how to repair tools like Sanders
and drills the most important thing for
us is to convince young men to stay in
Senegal far too many of them want to
leave the country they get into those
tiny overcrowded boats and die on the
journey the financial support from
Germany doesn't cover all its costs so
the group tops up its funding by
repairing electrical appliances brought
here by customers from all over the
country
and as fail a strong team spirit is
important trainers and students eats
lunch together every day making contact
with potential employers is a key part
of the training course along with the
trainer's Dame Silla is visiting some of
the local workshops and teas many of the
mechanics now running their own
workshops also learnt they traded a
spell like o ma ba and they want and
need fresh talent its you do listen if
all Senegalese or all Africans went to
Europe there wouldn't be anyone left
here in Africa Europeans developed
Europe we Africans have to develop
Africa that's why I'm training up a
couple of boys so they have a future
here soon after work de Mesilla heads
over to the other side of town the 27
year old lives with his uncle's extended
family his own parents live in the
capital Dhaka they want their only son
to stay in Senegal I'm my mother's only
son she really doesn't want me to get in
one of those boats recently my sister
jokingly brought up the topic and my
mother got really angry
she said that anything I could achieve
in Europe I could also do here
you made them dude fare I'm the fuqua as
soon as he arrives home the phone rings
a friend wants damn Scylla to fix a
motor he has to go his apprenticeship is
already paying off